hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the Masters
today we're going to look at how a
single mother on welfare followed her
passion for writing and became the first
billion-dollar author and highest
earning novelist in history this is a
story of JK Rowling and the top three
lessons that you can learn from her
success JK Rowling is a British author
best known as a creator of the harry
potter fantasy series rolling was a
single mother living on welfare working
as a secretary was not how she had
envisioned her life she had admittedly
reached her own personal rock bottom
without even enough money to pay the
electricity bill rolling knew she had to
do something to provide a better life
for her and her baby daughter but what
she wondered the answer came to her
while riding the train one day that was
when Harry Potter came to life after
completing the first Harry Potter book
twelve publishers rejected it but number
13 proved to be the lucky one within a
few months Rowling's Harry Potter
character had come to life between the
pages of a book in England a few months
after that the American rights to the
novel were bought for a hefty sum with
that rolling finally quit her teaching
job and decided to focus full-time on
writing today the store is rolling first
wrote in coffee shops have become famous
the world over not only has books but as
movies computer games music and more
she's the world's first billion-dollar
author and the highest earning novelist
in history the Potter books have gained
worldwide attention when multiple awards
sold more than 400 million copies I'm in
the basis for popular series of films in
2007 time magazine named rolling
runner-up for its Person of the Year and
2010 forbes estimated her net worth to
be 1 billion dollars
by following her passion am I never
giving up ruling gut off welfare and
went on to become a billionaire to help
you tap into your passion here are three
action items that you can learn from JK
Rowling action item number one get over
your fear of failure nobody wants to
fail but you can't let the fear of
failing prevent you from making
important decisions in your life
anything that's worth doing will come
with a healthy dose of fear successful
entrepreneurs are the ones who can plow
through that fear and come out
victorious on the other side rolling
couldn't believe the number of different
stories publishing houses gave her
that's why they didn't want to print her
manuscript her story was too long too
fantastical I wouldn't do well selling
to a mainstream audience they said she
remained patient and had faith in her
product she continued to send it out the
publishing houses until she found one
who saw in her story which she did a
success it was one year before the time
rolling finished her first Harry Potter
book to the time that a publisher
finally agreed to buy it and publish it
according to Rolling anything is
possible if you've got enough nerve I
was determined to try I was determined
to try because frankly my life was such
a mess at that point what what was the
worst that could happen everyone turned
me down big deal
action item number two make every second
count you only have so much time today
to get work done and as entrepreneurs we
usually have too many projects on the go
to keep track of it's hard work getting
the business off the ground and you need
to make every second count Harry Potter
came to life on a day that Rowling was
stuck on a train between manchester and
london during the four-hour delay
passenger sitting next to her might have
used the time to catch up on some sleep
but rolling was determined to use time
to her advantage whether it was a
15-minute break from her secretarial
duties at Amnesty International or 30
minute nap time break from her baby
daughter Rowland used every spare second
to dream up and jot down points for her
story according to Rolling where the
idea of Harry Potter actually came from
I really couldn't tell you I was
traveling on a train between manchester
and london and it just popped into my
head i spent four hours thinking about
what hogwarts would look like the most
interesting train journey I've ever
taken by the time I got off at Kings
Cross many of the characters in the
books had already been invented
action item number three love what you
do if you don't love what you do you're
not going to have much success as an
entrepreneur you're going to quit as
soon as it gets tough and you're not
going to make a meaningful contribution
to your community as with all matters of
the heart you'll know it's right when
you find it rolling wanted to make your
contribution to the world to add her
unique something that nobody else could
bring to the table and that unique
something was her writing she never went
searching for the kind of success that
she's received today she simply wanted
to do best but she loved most and that
was writing putting the rolling I just
write what I wanted to write I write
what amuses me it's totally for myself
I'm an extremely lucky person doing what
I love best in the world I'm sure that
I'll always be a writer
so remember get over your fear of
failure make every second count and love
what you do to finish up this video I
wanted to share one of my favorite true
stories of JK Rowling and some of her
best quotes Harry Potter was not an
instant success in fact at the very
first book reading rolling did for her
first Harry Potter novel only four
people showed up to hear her the staff
of the bookstore felt so sorry for her
that they stood around and listen to
Roland's editor then advised her to get
a day job since she had little chance of
ever making money in children's books
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modern masters if you enjoyed
the video please give it a thumbs up and
also love to hear your comments if you
leave some feedback below the video and
stay tuned for the next episode